welcome back to New rockstars this is a
reaction to the new trailer for
Spider-Man across the spider verse we
have not seen it yet I'm Eric Boss here
with me is Jessica Clemens and Mt good
morning guys yeah so we're gonna react
to this we're gonna go through some
highlights and then we're gonna talk
about the videos we're gonna make after
this in the days ahead but let's not
waste any more time here we go
do this little
let's get to the trailer
so neat oh I love the glitching
miles
I can hear you
[Music]
hear you I know
hope I didn't ice your game man oh I
like my parents those words in that
order
oh it's just you said a growth spurt see
my little man I'm not being my little
boy all the time
yeah
oh this art man for years I've been
taking care of this little boy
[Music]
oh we know Stanley
making sure he is loved he's just gonna
Recaps from the 2018 but he feels like
he belongs wherever he wants to be
he wants to go on to the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
um
I love you guys
it was they won't look out for you like
us
miles
wanna get out of here oh wherever you go
from here you have to promise to take
care of that little boy for me
wow
[Music]
Spider-Man Central
that he's loved
oh my God yes
[Applause]
tell him that oh that was all along
there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
please don't die
what here it comes here it comes
um
they're all drawn differently
we are supposed to be
we are
they don't know how to work together
Bros
now bro you mean the Fantastic the
bombastic Bag Man oh my God I'm gonna
I'm gonna eat it I need this in my
eyeballs immediately Sony
um I'm gonna need you to send me the
file uh to my Google email immediately
because my God like they've done it
again like I like the the beginning of
the trailer made me feel like I was
watching the movie because like it was
like a long thing I was like yeah we're
already here watching the movies I was
like oh no it's just a trailer I wonder
if they gave a lot away in that trailer
oh my God I think they do I mean we
don't see spot anywhere that is true yes
um so just to kind of give everyone a
big picture view of this uh Spider-Man
across the spider verse this is taking
up after that final scene of the 2018
film where Gwen Stacy just appears in
the portal over miles bed uh but like
some time has passed you know miles is a
bit older he's he's hit a growth spurt
between uh now in the past movie and uh
we're gonna be introducing it sounds
like six new universes in this movie we
got Issa Ray as a Jessica Drew Spider
Woman and she's pregnant in this movie
and I love that I love it superhero yeah
it's so much fun but Jason schwartzman's
gonna be the spot uh that's a the
villain who can just kind of open like
little portals and go through like spot
world or the spot first right it just
kind of appear on either side like over
here over here kind of like listening
style thing but it's awesome yes it's
very Looney Tunes we saw some of this
footage in a teaser that came out
sometime last year I can't remember when
that was but like we got to see Mom
Batten that's like the uh Peter have a
car the Indian Spider-Man and then we
see Oscar Isaac as uh as Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 2099 in Nuevo York you know
he's the one who actually has the
ability to navigate the spider verse it
sounds like the spider verse itself is
what we're visiting in this movie the
highlights I I can't talk right now I'm
sorry
but we're highlights for both of you
from this trailer I mean like obviously
we have to talk about that huge
Spider-Man like spider men women shot
there's so many spider people
um in that shot like that was a super
super iconic obviously the the huge shot
of like the spider verse like the the
webs and like the uh the web of life and
Destiny it seems where they are at and
the weird Blue Area it's Jess what were
you what were some highlights for you I
think the same but also Jessica Drew and
she's working with what I think was
Miguel O'Hara and the last shot that she
was featured in was her turning back and
looking and it's Miguel next hour so I'm
like what relationship is there looks
like she's fighting uh a volt like a
version of vulture but this can be
voiced by uh yorma tacon uh who voiced
Goblin in the uh 2018 film but if you
look closely he's like got this uh
Leonardo da Vinci Renaissance Italian
Renaissance style sketches it's like
it's kind of tan I like how they're
really pulling from throughout history
to give these artistic influences and to
give each character distinct uh animated
look to it that that Spider-Man like
grizzled Spider-Man I think that's just
Miguel O'Hara
um without his mask on his his face just
seems like he's gone through it you know
I'm like I wonder what he what he's gone
through and like what what his reality
looks like and like what happened before
he went on that uh Spider Journey at the
end of the first movie
um because yeah he definitely feels like
or maybe this is just something that
happens in the movie I don't know yeah
empty you shouted out the bombastic back
yeah yes we got to the Peter Parker
wears like when he's like got a symbiot
separated from him in the back of the
building right yes it is the it is when
we find out what the Symbiote is he he
visits the uh Fantastic Four when he
first comes in contact with it he's like
yo what is this and Mr Fantastic's like
yeah uh this is a symbiote and like you
shouldn't have it on you and so he takes
his suit off and uh they gave him one of
the Fantastic Four suits but he gets a
bag over his head doesn't have a mask
and he just is the bombastic Bag Man and
you could play as that it's Spider-Man
PS5
um which is fantastic I love it I love
it so much I think all of us right now
really just want to start going through
this frame by frame and there's so much
to go through let's do this together all
right uh so really uh Jess you have
spent a lot of time recently going
through the different uh incarnations of
Spider-Man who are gonna appear in this
movie
um there's so much in this trailer why
don't you do the Easter egg breakdown
for this yeah so you can try to identify
uh all these different Spider-Mans are
you good with that yes absolutely oh
gosh it's as I just want to read more oh
Issa Ray
so good
oh okay yeah yeah I'm very interested um
I've like with the 2018 movie Just
obsessed with the different animation
styles that they put into each of these
characters and how they'd like draw them
and design them to look distinct from
each other and they're worlds that are
associated with them to look distinct so
I'm gonna do a separate breakdown that
just digs into that because that's a
whole other whole other uh like rabbit
holes go down for this movie is is just
how they they bring these Comics to life
right so that will be a separate video
uh that comes out uh either you know
tomorrow or really the next day I think
after Jess's Easter egg breakdown and
then Mt as our theorist in Chief do you
mind tackling how the Multiverse how the
spider verse Works in this movie and how
it's different from how the Multiverse
works at the MCU oh yeah for sure and
like I I think that I also want to like
sort of look into like how it could be
the same because like we know from like
recent interviews that like they're sort
of teasing that the
um uh Tom Holland will be crying passing
over with the spiderverse so I'm trying
to see if like there's some secret
coordination with Kevin feige as well
um to see if like that's exciting to you
that's exciting connects here as well I
think we just need some rules though um
before we go down that theory uh Theory
Deep dive because I think we need uh
just because it is different at least
from the start and it's gonna look
different at the very least we're
talking about portals or or Illuminati
Multiverse hop in this this actually has
a texture to it which I think is really
cool oh yes for sure so like the rules
of like the spider verse is going to be
really interesting to tackle I think uh
I'm just excited to hear that both the
spot is going to be the villain it
sounds like both of this movie across
the spider-verse in the next movie in
2024 beyond the spider verse so it's not
gonna be awarded in this movie but he is
a very difficult villain to kill because
he isn't really kind of made of the same
uh matter that we are or at least he can
kind of transcend reality or realities
in different ways do we think that uh
just a question I want to post to the
two of you do you think the spot is
going to be a symptom of some bigger
crisis in the spider-verse or do we
think he is the cause of the crisis in
the spider-verse I would say the cause I
think that like whatever he's doing is
going to Domino into a bigger bigger
crisis in the uh the third movie and um
he's just like he probably just has a
really selfish motivation but like he
doesn't he doesn't know the cosmic
consequences of what he's going to do
and um it's probably just going to make
it worse so yeah I think that is going
to be the first Domino into something
worse yeah I think spot is messing up a
lot of things uh in a very selfish
manner and I think it's them trying to
stop it but in an interview they did say
that spot and Miles uh are more
tight like closely related than what
appears to be so I think maybe spot the
I don't think spot's gonna die it's
gonna be another Peter Parker situation
where it's like not everyone deserves to
die we can fix them
yeah fix everybody but
um yeah I think it's gonna be revealed
that he's something more and his selfish
needs are probably Justified I I like
the idea that uh and this is something
that they do really well in all their
movies Lord Miller and their whole team
of animators is they give every
character their I mean it is a selfish
desire but it's something that's
understandable like you know Kingpin in
the 2018 film yeah you understand where
he was coming from now yes he pushed it
too far but they give every character
and no one is just irrational or just
evil for Evil's sake so that's my
thinking with spot as well it's gonna be
someone we really sympathize with and uh
and it seems like you know now that
we're expanding into the spider-verse
and we're meeting hundreds potentially
of different Spider-Man what's going to
be the thing that brings the ball
together is that sense of family you
know or that sense of shared Brotherhood
across uh across Dimensions so maybe
spot is like the outcast among them like
someone who either was uh ostracized or
just didn't fit in uh in his own in his
own reality and in the spider-verse
first in the web of life and Destiny
they're like Ugh you're not welcome here
too imagine the kid being bullied in
high school who then goes to college and
says they'll understand me here and
they're even worse at college and the
rest of their life you know
um maybe that's what we're dealing with
spot I mean I think Jason Schwartzman
being cast in it that's I'm just like
why would you catch Jason's shorts I
think right you know you need someone
who who's been who can be beat up a
little bit 100 but so but what do you
why do you guys think um although
Spider-Man are gathered in this spot
like do you guys think that they're
running from something like in the the
comic run oh like they're hiding uh yeah
they don't seem to be concerned they
seem to be like chilling and strolling
around it kind of looks like the The
Citadel and Rick and Morty yeah like
right or at least they they may be
hiding but they seem pretty comfortable
there was protected even though there
were different variations of Spiderman
there was still Spider-Man like cop that
was directing traffic so I don't think
they're in a rush I think they were just
like this is where we go for breaks this
is where we go for breaks I would like
more deeper meaning that like maybe
their planets exploded incursions happen
and they have to now live in this weird
universe but I think they're just like a
universe to pass through yeah I think I
I would love if it was like a safe Zone
that like if they were running from
something that like that something
couldn't find them in that zone so they
they got super comfortable it's like
yeah this is home now because we can't
really go anywhere else
um so yeah no I I'm really interested to
learn like what that place is I just
love that it has different gravity or
they're all just like comfortable using
their Spider-Man abilities to adhere
of miles and Gwen sitting like her
ponytail is going up so they're just
sitting upside down on something
um but like doesn't that require a lot
of effort to just like walk upside down
like just you know taking a morning
stroll why why Sprint why jog just
stroll hey they're flexing like I would
do that same [ __ ] be like oh look it's
just casual for me you know I'm just I'm
just a spider person super strength you
know that's what I do okay so again um
the three videos that are gonna be
coming out this week and we'll be doing
more beyond that but I just want to give
everyone a sense of what's what's
happening Jess is going to be doing our
Easter egg breakdown coming out next on
the channel uh followed by my animation
details breakdown we're gonna go uh and
then and then empty is going to do our
our Multiverse logic and rules breakdown
coming out after that so watch all three
of these videos I'm excited to see what
YouTube come up with because uh uh
because I I yeah I I just want to spend
time looking at the colors to be honest
I know right oh my God like the when
when miles and his mom were talking I I
just was looking at the backgrounds
being like I cannot wait for this movie
just for the art like the art is always
just like
mind-blowingly amazing and like I cannot
wait to see what um Lord and Miller's
people have put together because this is
going to be another Masterpiece
instantly and I can already tell another
Masterpiece the three of us need to
Scurry back to our quarters of the blue
dungeon to toil away for the rest of the
day for you all so uh thank you in
advance for your patience uh be sure to
follow new rock stars on all social
media and subscribe under rock stars you
can uh follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clements follow MTM ascertainment follow
me at EA boss uh but like don't tweet is
asking where's the video because we're
gonna be working we're gonna be working
until you see it we're gonna be telling
them when you're trying to make it as
great as we can for you in our editors
too like they put in so much work so
like please please but we love all you
thank you so much let us know in the
comments below your favorite part of
this trailer what you're most looking
forward to from across the spider versus
beyond the spider verse and uh we'll see
you soon bye everybody
foreign